I want to wear things that make me feel  good about myself and still feel sexy  kim kardashian seems to be pretty  comfortable nearly new - here she is in  husband Kanye West's latest fashion  campaign posing in bed topless with just  underwear and Yeezys on Kim previously  struck this strange pose captioned like  butter to promote her husband's line  which was quickly Mima fide by the  internet check out Colton Haynes  mimicking the pose she's really lit and  fine and crazy and just all digital all  digital and all fun the 37 year old  seems to be enjoying the jokes reposting  many of the memes on her Instagram story  it's not that serious guys check out Kim  as a Toy Story toy with the caption and  he's coming the reality star as literal  butter on a stack of pancakes and here  she is hilariously taking down her  competitor in a wrestling match  you  [Music]